violette klaus et prune ils étaient
trois enfants intelligents mais leur
quotidien se résume est un mélange de
guigne d'un fortune et de malheur vos
parents tous les deux péri dans un
terrible incendie perry veut dire qu'ils
sont cuits nous savons ce que perry veut
dia bonjour bonjour bonjour mes chers
enfants
je suis le comte olaf votre nouveau
tuteur vous savez ce que c'est via une
liste fo c'est la liste de vos corvées
mais on sait ce que vous voulez c'est la
fortune de nos parents qu'il faut
quitter cet endroit maudit posture
l'intérieur en sécurité à l'abri de tous
les méchants des méchants mais où ça les
enfants baudelaire seront mises en
pièces
quand le sable se sera écoulé votre
fortune sera mienne je savais bien que
le sable s'est coulé aussi vite h et
trouver ça sur internet ce serait gentil
que vous leur tournée au moins deux ou
trois fois vos parents et moi aimions
développer nos propres codes secrets
nous parents développer des coachs dans
ma bibliothèque vous trouverez les
réponses à toutes les questions que vous
vous posez
on a dû travailler il se passe des
choses bizarres ici qu'est ce que c'est
ça appartenait à mes parents on dirait
le tatouage que le conte la falaise
tchad
je suis le capitaine jacques que vous
dit que c'est le conte au lave qui s'est
déguisée un tu m'as bien
où que vous soyez je vous traqueraient
pourquoi es tu veux toujours ces
méchants poste que je trouve sa mort
nous sommes en route pour une expédition
classés top secret qu'en dites vous des
baudelaire ça vous tente
vous conduire en prison bon courage
alors parce que je suis armé
moi aussi c'est sauf les enfantillages
mais comme il est mignon un fusil harpon